wouldn't therefore want to withdraw
simply because of IG the admittedly
disgraceful behavior of the Strasburg
Court over rule 39 in ruenda I've got
very little patient time for the ruenda
scheme I don't think it's going to work
but I think that the way that the
British courts were treated ever that
was and the British government was
treated were frankly disgraceful but I
don't think one should take single
incidents and treat them as a reason for
withdrawing that is just rhetoric I
would certain My Views are potentially
based on the experience of Decades of
Strasburg uh jurist Prudence uh and I
reg I originally felt we should perhaps
wait to see whether they could reform
themselves internally whether the
Brighton declaration would work I have
very reluctantly come to the conclusion
that this is too ungainly an institution
with too much esey decor and too much
ideological commitment to change